remember when WikiLeaks confirmed what
we all knew that governments and their
embassies lie to one another like crazy
the South Africa cables are basically
the same when it comes to spy agencies
they lie they spy they steal and
sometimes they ask each other for help
the cables consist of hundreds of
top-secret documents obtained by Al
Jazeera's investigative unit here are
four things about the world of spies
that the cables can confirm
one cable suspects Iran of using
civilian fronts in South Africa like
carpet shops to gather information
the cables also show that SSA suspects a
cultural group the Helen bait foundation
in Cape Town of being a spy front for
Tehran
it was called the assault on Pelle
Indaba what happened at Pelle Indaba is
the kind of thing that keeps presidents
awake at night suspected nuclear
terrorists attacked a South African
nuclear facility with handguns possibly
trying to steal highly enriched
weapons-grade uranium but in the cables
the SSA suspects the men were really
trying to steal the plans for a new type
of nuclear technology that South Africa
was working on the culprits they
suspected China
yep that's what happened when a North
Korean spy known to Britain's mi6 happen
to find himself briefly in transit in a
South African airport
mi6 sent an urgent cable to South
Africa's SSA asking them to please do
all they can to help turn him into a
double agent preferably by offering
money lots of it we never do learn what
happened in the end I guess what happens
in the business class lounge stays in
the business class lounge
ahead of the 2010 g20 summit in Seoul
South Korea asked South Africa for some
help they wanted information on a couple
of dangerous individuals who might be
attending the summit in addition to two
men South Korea asked for a security
assessment of a third man also a South
African national the head of Greenpeace
Kumi Naidoo after what Greenpeace did to
those Nazca lines in Peru
maybe the Koreans were just ahead of the
curve too soon
you